UFOs exist the US government found quite
a number of them and they are indeed of
non-human origin I'm just gonna go no we
have spacecraft from another species
there are no aliens
do we have the bodies of the pilots the
pilot of this craft non-human biologics
came with some of these recoveries
we're definitely not alone
is not real
[Music]
facts don't care about your feelings
this catchy cliche was coined by Ben
Shapiro owner of the popular
conservative news Outlet the daily wire
Mr Shapiro recently targeted me in a
public smear campaign after I provided a
mountain of evidence proving the
existence of aliens for some reason he
refused to acknowledge the fact that we
are simply not alone
[Music]
well Matt Walsh is a very controversial
person for a number of reasons dude
really thinks that like the aliens are
here let's take this logically for just
a moment to destroy mount with facts and
Logic the evidence you're presenting me
is gonna have to be better than a guy
saw a shadowy image that appeared to
defy the laws of physics probably it's
aliens again there's a question of
likelihood Matthew you have nothing I'm
sorry you have nothing there are no
aliens on planet Earth I don't believe
it I don't see the evidence for it and I
think all of this is a giant waste of
time
sympathy poured in from around the world
to comfort Mr Shapiro after this public
embarrassment however he continues his
anti-alien campaign to this day this
irrational alienophobia while easily
dismissed as quackery
raises the question
does Ben Shapiro pretend to hate aliens
because he is one
to protect the Integrity of this
investigation all of the evidence you're
about to be presented was collected by
our trained investigators using the most
advanced strategies equipment and
techniques
we'll finally learn if the one who smelt
it dealt it
in 2021 young America's Foundation
hosted a speech at Florida State
University featuring Ben Shapiro
at this event Mr Shapiro demonstrated
alien mind control capabilities in front
of a live audience hi Ben how are you
doing okay how are you great
um how come you claim to be five nine
even though you're like five five
I don't know how tall are you
you're five nine I'm actually five now
okay come over here let's see
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
spatial perception is affected by
distance so considering the student in
the video was close enough to see Mr
Shapiro it's reasonable to assume he was
close enough to accurately judge his
height yet the young man's calculations
were off by four inches
take another look
[Applause]
a leaning expert on extraterrestrials
testified on Twitter that aliens possess
the ability to control human Minds
make us see things differently than they
really are
did Ben Shapiro alter his perception in
order to publicly own him
does this explain all of the college
students Shapiro has destroyed
[Music]
according to Wikipedia Ben Shapiro was
born in January of 1984 in Burbank
California
our researchers checked online for any
birth announcements with the name Ben
Shapiro in 1984
and found nothing
aside from a certified birth certificate
no evidence exists that anyone named Ben
Shapiro was born on that day in Burbank
or anywhere else
renowned physicist Stephen Hawking made
a startling confession at some point
before his death that unlike his
contemporaries who speculated aliens are
friendly explorers he believed aliens
might actually hate humans
their evidence Ben Shapiro is hostile
towards Humanity
our team pieced together this video from
Clips they found on the daily wires
website
the company tried to suppress this
evidence behind countless hours of newer
content but but we were able to uncover
shocking
[Music]
why do I hate Michael moles because the
gods have smiled upon Michael malls for
no reason I can discern
what the I'm gonna be trapped in a
locked room with Michael Knowles for a
given period of time which sounds
technically like the definition of Hell
Michael Knowles a man who only fails
upward you went to Yale I could not find
any any other productive thing that you
had done in your entire life Michael
moles a man hired at this company for
one job did not do that job well and so
was given a podcast we were an
unemployable person so we apparently
just kept paying you yeah and then I'm
gonna just hand this over to you we'll
take a picture for the camera it's
really incredible there we go thank you
absolutely no no no we've had many
complaints about you walking around
shirtless in the office see in the movie
The pedophile is outside the room never
go in the dressing room when Knowles in
there five more minutes and now he's
gonna Marie and eat you yeah that's why
Michael moles will eventually pay the
ultimate price when I run him over with
my car
we reached out to Mr Shapiro for comment
right before recording this video but
our email went unanswered
for more information and a closer look
at the evidence visit Ben Shapiro might
be an alien.com
foreign
[Music]